it's an obsession well you know I mean
somebody couldn't make ninety-five
percent of your energy right so if
you're my Taccone don't work you'll not
be smiling at me and not be getting off
this chair you not be hearing what I'm
saying right so these are hallmarks of
mitochondrial dysfunction and they lead
to organ toxicity and disability and so
knowing that you know drugs can target
mida kanya and that I can actually
screen for that and you know prevent
that so I can choose components that
work but they don't have these
liabilities and I think they're so I
think the reason why people didn't know
about it is because it is such a you
know complicated little bugger with so
many different mechanisms it's very very
complex so that you know when I said
it's it's job security it's too because
we're just at the rudimentary
understanding you know of what they
actually do but we do know if they don't
work where we're in big trouble so it
seems like I've done this for 15 years
and every year learned something new and
and it just never stops it's challenging
every day and
you